Hey, I'm Walter, your instructor.
After learning all the cool
things you can do with code,
writing documentation
might seem a bit stale.
I'm here to show you why that's,
in fact, not the case and
why you should get excited
about documenting your code.
In this course you'll be cooking
up your very own readme file.
You'll learn what documentation is and
why it's an important part of
the development process and
you'll be able to incorporate it
into your projects moving forward.
This course is relevant to
anyone who either writes code or
works with others who do.
Throughout this course, you'll be
seeing examples of documentation for
a variety of tools and languages, some
will be familiar and others will not.
That's okay.
Focus on the concepts, not the actual
code that we'll be documenting.
To help us get started, I've cooked
up a little something for you.
How does this relate to readme's?
Well, you'll understand in a minute.